hello
and welcome to our talk today on
fractional order differentiation in the
wolfram language and
in particular the wolfram function
repository
um my name is paco jane i'm a research
programmer in the wolfram alpha
department and with me today is oleg
marachov he's a
been working with special functions in
calculus for many years and as an expert
in the field yes for beginning
of our talk paco described
history and subject and i will continue
with formulas thank you all right
so you can view our abstract at your
leisure
first of all what is a fractional order
integral well
um as we learn in a regular calculus
class we can
compute derivatives we can compute
integra integrals
and we learn that integration is the
sort of the inverse of
differentiation via the fundamental form
of theorem of calculus
uh so in other words we can you know and
and because these things are repeatable
we could
compute an uh integral to some any
integer order you know you could do
repeated integration seven or nine or a
hundred times
same thing with differentiation um so
you can kind of think of
those falling on a number line with
negative numbers representing
integration
positive numbers or differentiation well
a mathematician of course might come
along and say can we
generalize this
for instance can we think about or or
talk
about um a different a derivative that's
not an
integer order but maybe a half integer
order or
any in general any real number uh order
of integration or differentiation
and the answer is yes we can find a
consistent uh definition of
uh of how to work with these things um
just to give you a quick flavor of how
something
mathematically you might go about
defining this sort of abstract concept
is uh let's say we have a generalized
power function
uh x to the k power and we decide we
want to
um integrate it excuse me take the
derivative
um we get this result here of well-known
result um
now let's just naively decide that we're
going to let n
be a non-integer power so excuse me uh
a non-integer order of differentiation
well in that case we're just going to
replace the symbol n
with alpha where alpha is any real
number and then
we know that from euler that the
generalization
of a factorial function is this gamma
function a special function
so we can sort of just do the naive
thing and then
for any given function we want to
differentiate can operate on taylor
series we sum the t
the results in terms of uh incomplete
gamma functions and boom
we've got a at least one definition of a
fractional order integral
um that's just to give you a flavor of
how these things are developed there's a
lot of history that goes
that goes into the study of these things
and
there are some points listed here i'm
not going to read them all off for you
because you can read those for
yourself but there here's a little
timeline graph of
when some of the important contributions
have happened
historically to the this field um
moving forward we're going to skip ahead
to a particular definition
called the riemann louisville fractional
integral integral derivative and it's
defined
uh via the formula here you can see that
it's in
all cases an integral transform of some
kind involving gamma functions
uh except of course in the alpha equals
zero case which just returns the
function itself
um this is an important uh definition
and
one that's used frequently in the field
so it's the one that we've actually
implemented
uh in the resource function that we'll
be talking about today
there are other definitions um there
they will all agree
on the derivative operator for integer
alpha but
may disagree on for non-integer alpha
for instance another
common commonly used um definition comes
from bren
renwild and litnikov it's particularly
attractive because
you can sort of always solve numerical
fractional integral differential
equations
um due to the properties of that
particular definition
but suffice to say there are many
examples there's over 50 listed
in the appendix to this talk and more
details in general about the history you
can find in our references section
so let's go on and just talk about some
of the basic mathematical properties of
these
um derivative operators uh
they form a continuous group in the
sense that if you take
uh the alpha derivative and then the
beta derivative it's like taking the
overall the alpha plus beta derivative
of a function
and that's for any true for any function
and these semi-group properties are nice
because they form
a continuous semi group and so you know
there's
a lot of interesting mathematics that
can be done there um
one thing to caution uh those of you who
are new to this field about is that
sometimes our intuition doesn't actually
i should say our intuition from regular
calculus doesn't necessarily carry over
into this
new realm for instance in general when
you take the derivative
of a constant the fractional derivative
you don't get zero
which is maybe a little bit shocking um
just in terms of applications these uh
uh
equations involving these uh types of
derivatives
are associated in terms of physical
systems or or other um
application systems uh where where
there's a concept of memory in other
words that the dynamics
at a given time depend perhaps on state
variables
at a different time uh that would be
in contrast to say newton's second law
where f equals m a and we're talking
about the force and acceleration at the
same time
um and uh finally we just
will show you just some visualization to
show you how
these things smoothly interpolate
between
uh different integer order
differentiations so here we just take a
sine function very simple
and compute the fractional order uh
derivative
and then plot it and you can see that
it's just smooth as
alpha is varied between 3 and negative
3.
um this is just another uh goes into a
little bit more detail about some of the
different applications
i'm not going to read through these here
but there's quite some interesting
physical systems including
you know everything very esoteric like
quantum mechanics all the way to
something
you know very um uh you i guess you
could say mundane or
down to earth groundwater flow analysis
um and just to show you how the field
has changed and grown
throughout the years i've got this chart
here that shows you citations that
involve the words fractional integration
fractional
differentiation over time you can see
that this year alone
so far there are 1800 articles back in
2011 there were 760 and if you click on
this page you can get some more of this
this data and you can see um how the
trends of
the you know this this field has really
exploded in the last
few years
moving on whoops a little too far
[Music]
scroll up uh okay so
the main uh result of the work that
we're showing you here today is this
resource function and you can see this
sort of blobby thing
that in the wolfram language is uh it
behaves
very much like a built-in function um
however it goes and gets the code um
dynamically from the wolfram function
repository
i've clicked i've created a link here so
you can see the documentation page for
this function it's just like a built-in
function and that has documents you can
click to copy examples all that neat
stuff that comes with the
faction repository and then we can you
know test it out on some simple things
to make sure it works and this is
the result you would expect maybe try it
again with a sine function in general
when alpha's not an integer you get a
very complicated thing
involving hypergeometrics but in certain
integer cases it reduces
just as you'd expect it to um
uh just some some algorithmic uh
talk about how we the different
approaches we use to compute these
things
there's a few different sort of tracks
you can go through for
for uh some sort of simple functions
there are just generic formulas that are
known
and we converted these to pattern
matching rules and replacements
on the other hand for the bulk of
functions uh we use the power of myergy
reduce which is
new and also a meyer g form function uh
which oleg developed which
converts any generic function into an
expression involving minor g
and then we do simple replacements for
the derivative we know what the
the um alpha order derivative of the
meyer g function is
so about 60 of the 82 000 uh
examples that we'll talk about later
that we tested this on
uh go through this sort of code path uh
my rg reduce
and then finally there are some generic
formulas for composition and things like
that that
um for fractional differentiation
where you can produce results that
involve hypergeometric functions of
multiple variables for instance apple f1
laura cella and so forth
uh lorachel is actually not implemented
yet but it's coming
in the near future um i mentioned myergy
a lot so just some
quick background um you know all kinds
of um simple
uh um elementary functions i should say
can be written in terms of the power
function
right we're used to that um and if you
generalizing more generically
almost any combination of these things
uh
can you know at least if you're talking
about
uh functions of the hypergeometric form
which is a large subset
um you can eventually express it in
terms of
a irg function and my rg functions are
defined
uh through contour integration in terms
of gamma functions so they're
quite complex but uh the nice thing is
that
once we know how to convert to my energy
form taking the fractional derivative
becomes quite easy here is the formula
that we've
um shows how you do the derivative right
there
moving forward just some quick
properties and
relations of these things note that
the resource function results agree with
the regular
derivative and integral operators in the
wolfram language
when you're reduced to the uh
to the integer case okay that the
results match up
in that sense uh you can do repeated
integrations
uh in one fell swoop just by using a
large
number over here um and then finally we
can compare to
sort of the calculated the actual
integral if we
look back at our definition of the
riemann louisville integral and see that
the result is the same so um just some
sanity checks if you will
all right um moving forward
take over and you can describe more
about the back end of
the mathematics as you see above
in reality have had
classical integral differentiation of
fractional order
if we use option generate condition
false for our integrate
but we developed this
idea and we
also implemented
new lines
connected with fractional integral
differentiation
for example here you see
that fractional order derivative
of that in degree cell
gives peace wise uh
and psy's on set position include
classical result which uh paco mentioned
and on a middle line you see
something new and it comes when
we have uh
situation like alpha equal minus
1 um alpha equal one
and say equal minus one and logarithm
appeared after integration we mentioned
about this
um what's new in our
we supported
it means functions which
after differentiation gives zero
it is a square root x squared divided by
x or something like a different plot of
logarithms
turning to the derivative 0
and if we make a fractional integral
differentiation
we produce this constructions
5 in again you see
here the result and
also in our research
we implemented piecewise for example
here
you see that
after derivative
we see two cases
if integer alpha positive
we produce polywork and otherwise for
arbitrary symbolical alpha we produce
this big construction with polygama
and the same was done to many other
functions
also what's new we solved problem
uh we've connected with
algorithm i mentioned you
because if you expand for example
this in k in 0 you will get
logarithm in
serious expansion and for
evolution fractional derivatives of each
term we need to know uh how to create
fractional derivatives of such
construction
which you see here and we made
solutions this is example
we have generic formulas and programs in
this area
and also as i mentioned we
related integrals
the integrals using linear g
representation
for example here we have series from
basic
k 0 z and and we can represent
through mirz using a new
energy reduce which i don't demonstrate
here
and then we can make fractional
derivative of this mean energy
representation and get result
you see this result here
by the way we can get two
forms for this result
practically all existing
forms for fractional integral
differentiation
in particular very well known form
is a very fractional integral
and here you see
this comparison uh
between you know our
results and that this refraction
derivatives
can be converted to riemann reveal
derivatives but here i use
notations in mathematical
genetic condition pulse as example
for demonstrate that revolution gives a
correct result everywhere you can see
true true
and so on um and for
the recorded fractional integral
here another example we can introduce
each these notations for
the recorder it is
that in degrees minus 10 degrees sigma
instead
zeta minus square internal
uh and we evaluate
this result for function
zeta degrees c and
we see how to avoid
the mathematica is a little
buggy in this area but in any case
the wing nicely
and right now i will say that
we have a rather huge
test collection 82 000
which runs with speed
10 integrals
no with such speed you see
10 3 yeah
and we selected several
uh examples and only and you see table
how
uh we need a fractional integral
derivative from this
and uh also
in conclusion uh you see
reference i am close with
some cohen kilbus off very huge
manor of about one thousand pages
we published in 1993
it includes a bibliography about 2000
references
about history and
many many new results in this area
till that time but right now we
see many many new publications
for the last 30 years
and in particular you can see
the table of different representations
different definitions for fractional
integrals here cover
type uh type chain
integral
integral and many others
with this
[Music]
available for public thank you for
attention thank you very much um
we hope that you try out this function
the resource function that we have
and uh give us some feedback tell us
what you think if you've noticed any
bugs let us know through the feedback
form on the webpage
and thank you very much
you